civilization six got your full reviews
up we did like an ask the reviewer type
thing about a week ago when you first
got it
you seemed pretty positive on you said I
had some annoyances but your review is
now up I want to talk briefly about the
score before we get into like the
segment itself is just like where does
this fall on the grand scheme of the
civil'zation series which is 25 years
old as of like last month or something
but what what led you to give to 9 score
why do you like this game so much that's
that's a big question I spent a lot of
words answering that question it's it's
tough and actually it was a bit tricky
to score I definitely considered giving
it at 8 certain points simply because
there are some frustrations with it I
mean there's some things about the UI
that still really annoy me and the AI
the AI opponent and singleplayer are
definitely not perfect I didn't have
nearly as much trouble with them as
certain people in our comments who were
like it's broken it's the games I can't
even play it which was not my experience
even if occasionally the a I would do
stupid things but setting that aside
even those issues never stopped me from
wanting to continue playing it is just
such an engrossing experience and
discovering all of the nuances that have
been added since if five and learning
all about the big changes which we've
discussed at length previously including
like unstacking cities and active
research and agendas for for for leaders
I mean all these big changes make it
really fascinating to me as a longtime
Civ fan for someone who's not super
familiar with the franchise because like
everything you just said makes sense to
me because I love the franchise and
people that really want to play this and
have been waiting for it for months or
like because they didn't even announce
it until about May or June they can kind
of said hey there's a sip six the next
numbered entry it's not beyond Earth
it's not an expansion this is the next
number ten treats coming out four months
not always the case but for someone who
doesn't really understand the franchise
and like was considering getting into it
is sip six a good entry point I would I
would say it is actually yeah I don't
think that any of the games are any
better or worse a place to jump in
because no matter where you start Civ is
a bit demanding um I was actually
talking to Jake Decker one of our video
producers who was just playing sip for
the first time he started with sip six
and and I think that starting in the
series there is a pretty daunting
learning curve because there are a lot
of systems at play and there's a lot to
just remember and manage in any even
playthrough
that said though I think that civics
does an elegant job of inserting its new
ideas in in in a way that makes sense
that slots naturally into the structure
and and the overall structure of the
game is very understandable I mean
you're establishing a civilization right
and you're taking it very slowly step by
step from a single settler and a single
warrior up through the Space Age right
so it'll every match evolves very
gradually and so if you take your time
and you're willing to put in the hours
and into a full playthrough by the end
of that first playthrough I feel like
anybody will have a firm grasp of what
the game is like and what it entails and
that remains true for Civ six and there
is a full tutorial for Civ six as well
that's like fully voiced and pretty
brisk and I think it really will help
new players so in my mind this is this
is a great place to start if you've
never played a stiff game yeah and
that's the thing that's tough with these
kind of games and we did a recent video
shoot it for access in Maryland a lot of
them express the same sentiment that
it's a series that they almost nailed
the formula back with like I mean even
like Civ 3 the last game with this like
sprites before once like 3d with Civ for
like that far back it's almost like they
nailed that board game slash simulation
kind of turn-based you know one more
turn formula so with each entry it's all
like what features are they going to
change obviously unstacking the cities
whereas they used to be on one tile now
you're like spreading them across
multiple districts on different hex
tiles but you know like active research
becomes a sidequest kind of thing almost
with the science that can boost and like
maybe turn you a different direction or
like boost like the paths are going down
but it's almost like where does Civ 6
fall in the pantheon of Civ games in
terms like the improvements they've made
because SIF 5 releasing it was imperfect
what's most things are but SIF 5 release
was really good but there are a lot of
things wrong with it but then you know
gods and kings and brave new world came
out the expansion it's like this is the
game step 5 should have been like can
you see I'm making certain changes to 6
that'll like kind of maybe make it like
not like objectively but a really good
game in the series uh well so this this
is a pretty big question in a difficult
question to answer especially you know
within the first week of the game's
release because as you pointed out Civ
games have a habit of growing pretty
substantially after release so
inevitably I think there will be a lot
of big changes in big additions to 6
that we haven't yet seen and honestly
there's still plenty of stuff about the
base game that I'm still coming to grips
with and learning about and you know
figuring out how it all
kind of connects together but I will say
that the base game I I think as I said
in review I think sip six is the
strongest base game civilizations ever
released it is certainly stronger than
sip five was when it first came out so
if I was actually pretty bare-bones in a
lot of ways when it first released and
and the the DLC that came later fleshed
it out into this really rich in deep
experience so arguably the best Civ
experience you could have is sieve 5
plus all of these share expanded content
I think sip 6 actually kind of matches
that experience in a lot of ways but
it'll kind of boil down to preference I
mean I think with every new civilization
there's a certain set of players who
remain behind continue to play the
experience they know in experience they
love and I'll see that's fine it's kind
of a matter of taste because six really
does change a lot of things and not
everybody's gonna love those things so
saying it's best is like such a
hopelessly subjective thing and and you
know so I think that six is great I
think it's the strongest base game for
sure I think there's stuff that they
could add to make it even stronger but I
think that veterans will find stuff that
makes it feel new and fresh and it's
genuinely exciting and like I said
before I think it's a good entry point
for new players as well sure and it's
actually it was like fascinating to look
at because the team that made the
expansions for Five's team that made six
so it's like ed Beachley designer these
are the people that like kind of almost
you know like really iterated on five to
the point of like like you said with
brave new world and gods and kings this
is kind of that's that itself as exists
now might be one of the better yeah you
know object Avengers in the series and
you can see a lot of those ideas in six
already you can see that that six
doesn't really follow five it follows
the expansions right it feels like the
next logical progression from from that
point not from the last base game like
the espionage is intact from the
expansions right that kind of system
yeah and social policies as well and
kind of like revamped but are similar to
how they were in the expansions yeah I
mean those I mean those ideas came a bit
later so a lot of like that has been you
know expanded upon included in the base
game that was not present at all in the
base version of civilization 5 so you
how many hours you put in by now about
60 something like that since last like
Thursday what 4 or 5 yeah I know about 4
so I I won with every possible win
condition which is a uh well actually
know one of my first game was
technically a score victory
so it's culture science religion
endowment
four ways you can win so I pursued all
of those the first time I actually
didn't successfully complete a science
thing I was very nearly under rent at a
time I just went through school yeah but
I had been pursuing science and that
first playthru a few months ago when we
had the preview build and I think one of
us like I saw it at a judge week
bat-like back during the summer I've
played a fair amount of this game even
though I haven't played that much like
post-release but you and I had a
conversation about how it kind of avoids
that boring mid game like how does the
flow of each match I kind of talk to you
during the ask your viewer but I want to
touch in there for people who might have
seen it because like now it's fully up
the review like 9 out of 10 you really
love this game but how does the actual
flow of each match go from like the
beginning to end because the beginning
150 turns are always the ones we like to
me they're the most fun it's most people
in the most fun that's when you're
planning things out fighting barbarians
kind of discovering other civilizations
natural wonders the villages that give
you gifts and whatnot
how does like each playthrough kind of
progress do you ever get bored in a
specific spot each time not in the same
spot each time there are certain things
like with science that kind of drags out
a little bit at the end because you're
just waiting like ah bill you know
finish researching this particular space
thing that I need to win the game you're
just like waiting for the turns to pass
away but I think that in previous
civilization games there was always kind
of a point where you could mentally
check out a bit at least for a little
while in the middle as you waited for
your big picture decisions to pan out I
think I use that exact phrase in the
review actually but this time around I
think unstacked
City is what you mentioned earlier
helped keep you engaged throughout the
biggest one of the biggest changes at
least that the unstack cities bring is
there's no longer a global happiness and
food level instead it's managed on a
local basis which means you have to pay
a lot more attention to individual
cities which is both um not tedious but
definitely demanding but it also creates
a lot of opportunities for strategic
gain so even though you are investing
time in this new way it actually can pay
off and and it does keep you invested it
does keep you immersed in the experience
more deeply because each term matters
there's something that you have to
accomplish on any given turn that can
contribute to your overall goals it's no
longer just okay I gotta wait for this
technology to finish researching so I
can then move forward there's always
something in the immediate turn you can
be doing to improve chances there's
always this weird disconnect to talk
like bigger picture for a second
civilizations been around for 25 years
since 1991 and despite the fact that
like now
not like if we went to the GameSpot
office right now and stuff like how many
people want to play six six I'm sure a
lot of people want try it out but like I
think like in terms of diehard people
that have been sticking with it there's
me there's you there's probably a few
others but it still seems sort of niche
even though it's one of the biggest
names and like turn-based strategy in a
lot of ways they have shaped the Forex
strategy honor and influence like even
realtime strategy in some respects I
don't know like Pete have you ever been
interested in or played this series that
much I've played a few Forex games
before that I've really enjoyed I played
like a really sieve endless space a few
years ago I thought was pretty awesome
and I really want a place if sex as much
as I really wanted to play sieve 5
because my hobbies my job so much of my
time is spent playing games I just don't
have that much time to play something
like 6 to really like sit down and
dedicate all those extra hours which is
unfortunate but I definitely want to
play it like I but I can imagine how for
a lot of people sieve might feel too
intimidating in terms of like I can't
wrap my head around this immediately
like I know what a first-person shooter
is I know what a platformer is I can
imagine that Civ is this complicated
simulation game but do I really know
what that means do I really want to take
you know I want to take the effort to
figure that out but I can imagine for a
lot of people well that might seem like
almost a chore in and of itself yeah to
get started yeah I mean like in recent
months and years we've kind of stopped
looking at addicting games as a good
thing like I think in old reviews if you
read them and say this game's addicting
as hell like not attend like this you
need to play this but Civ like despite
how boring it can sound the fact that
you're macro and micro managing this
civilization from the beginning of time
to the future it really is that's like
their mantra is one more turn and like
it's hard to like really get bored when
there's always something to worry about
like a new research to complete a new
building to finish like in this case new
district to build like your city's gonna
be unfolding you could build the Sphinx
you could build the pyramids why not
it's always kind of been really fun to
me for whatever reason but it's always
hard you explain it well in your review
why it is fun and engaging but again
like this series is so intimidating it's
crazy it's been around for 25 years like
not many series have it's like no no no
like there's Mario there Zelda stuff
like that but I don't know like tip 6
like in your opinion you said that this
kind of matches up with the version of
SIF 5 as it is now I I mean I would say
so yeah it is ultimately like I said
completely subjective because there are
enough big changes to 6
that not everyone who loves 5:00 in the
expansion's is necessarily going to love
six but in terms of like feature
richness and the way in which it all
slots together and sort of the logic
driving all of the interlocking systems
of the game yeah it's like an incredibly
robust
experience there's so much to sink your
teeth into to a phrase that I really
hate I don't know why I came out of my
mouth but there's just so much for your
brain to absorb and to think about and
just there's so many wheels turning at
any given time that yeah I think people
who are willing to put in time which the
game does demand are are going to be
completely engrossed and and to me that
the level of investment does of six does
rival what I experienced with five in
the expansion to be completely
subjective for you is this the best Civ
game you've ever played this is
certainly my favorite Civ game I guess
um and I've spent all mean I open the
review talking about like playing the
original civilization with my dad came
out when I was five years old but I
remembered be like all catapults are
awesome yeah I didn't really understand
the game bad I understood enough that I
kept playing it it's weird I'm like more
nostalgic about Civ that I'm about Mario
sure which is weird for someone my age
but completely true for whatever reason
definitely yes that's Civ six it is
released as of Friday the 21st we gave
it a 9 out Scott you gave it a 9 out of
10 our full review is up on GameSpot
along with a video of you if you want to
check that out go read that go watch it
let us know you think in the comments
below
you